okay are you ready to you thing we can
do this a bit faster first let's
factorize that will give us the roots
okay so i take out common factor all
good that leaves you in X minus 4 okay
so now I can actually before it the
differentiate you can see I've got the
roots here right namely at 0 and at four
also you're sort of anticipating a
feature here because that X cubes will
give you a not a single roared over by
the triple room right we actually
already know those are horizontal points
of inflection okay so let's just look
after that as we keep going through
first derivative gives you 4 X cubed
minus 12x squared okay so factorize what
can I take up for X square and that
leaves you with X minus 3 okay so that
gives me stationary points at x equals 0
& 3 okay last bit second derivative this
turns into 12x squared and this turns
into 24 x okay so i can take 12 x out of
that excuse me X minus 2 okay so now i
have possible points of inflection and
i've got two of them namely at zero
answer
okay so let's draw this guy
now this is a quartic okay so just like
with your cubic the leading coefficient
tells you generally what kind of shape
you're going to have okay so because
it's positive I'm expecting this kind of
thing okay so I'll keep that in mind as
I draw I've got roots at 0 and 4 0 and 1
2 3 4 okay again be careful for your
scale because they're going to come in
for us later okay I've got a stationary
point and I've got this possible point
of inflection at zero and again you can
verify but we sort of already know
you're going to get a horizontal point
of inflection at the origin okay now
since I'm coming down I'm going to label
that here ok again to double check if
you if your part a right where your part
1 was proved that there is a horizontal
point inflection at the origin okay this
wouldn't be quite enough wouldn't ok
we'd actually have to test the con
Calvin you on either side to show yeah
it's concave up and then it's going to
be concave down in a second ok ok what
other features have we got ok yeah we've
got the station point which is a
horizontal point of inflection already
accounted for that at three I'm
expecting another stationary point and I
don't know where like up down so I'm
going to put my three back in here three
to four is a 1-4 lots of 27 which is so
81 minus hundred a is minus 27 Yeah
right here so I'm way down here ok so
because I haven't put anything else on
I'm just going to say three here i'm
going to call that 3-27 okay and I'll
just have to watch for later on for
where my other points will be this is
going to be a stationary point ok I'm
expecting it to be a minimum ok because
this is the shape that I'm getting ok ok
let's keep going I've got my two
stationary points in place and now I've
got this horizontal infection check
another high point of
section 22 what so when x is equal to 2
y's so this is my first one I'm going to
get to the power 4 is 16 minus 4 lots of
eight which is 32 so this is minus 16 ok
so maybe 16 what's that it's a it's past
halfway isn't it so if I've got most to
hear thinking something like that ok
that's going to be 2 minus 16 point of
inflection ok do we have enough in our
heads so we're we're coming down here we
hit this horizontal inflection and Bend
ok then you're coming down you hit
another point of inflection bend here's
our turning point and then you come back
up and I've got a hit through four ok so
you ready we try it okay if there's one
part now here I've got to make sure I'm
this was concave up so I'm changing from
cabin here so this is concave down right
I change again 20 here we go I'm gonna
have to be steep up
and up let's go there we go yeah it's
close enough so you can see what I've
done just to make it really clear right
is I've made the points that critical
points super obvious so I've got like
big fat dots there so you can see that's
the point inflection I'm talking about
that's the minimum and so on okay and
yes I should label so that's how finding
the critical points and then clottey
them on a graph the top plays out and
this is the kind of detail that you'd be
expected to replicate okay does anyone